so now that we've got our first actual
fortnite Creator on the first yeah yeah
yeah you you are the first because none
of us like four yeah yeah so we can we
can actually
do the meme now guys so it's fortnite
overrated
okay A bit loaded bit loaded
um have you seen that Meme no I haven't
seen his name it's like these three
little like 10 year old kids
and it's like every podcast has that
Meme did they actually say that on the
podcast or was that just the caption
underneath I think it actually is the
yeah I think that's the original captain
and they just got meme so it's like it's
just how serious they're like yeah yeah
they're like damn is it though like [__]
let's discuss it
um look I mean ah kind of back in the
day I think it was properly rated now
I'd say maybe a bit overrated yeah right
right serious which I think we are I
think a lot of our audience isn't really
familiar with fortnite in general yeah
um is there kind of a way you can
encapsulate how you fortnite worked or
kind of had relation to your content and
how what your relationship to fortnite
was nah so it's like back when I first
started the fortnite kind of thing we've
just come off Pokemon go hype and did
you guys get around Pokemon go oh yeah
like
um uh so
um I played Pokemon go yeah but I didn't
have every day I didn't have a phone
that could run Pokemon go at the time
but when did Pokemon go come out 2016
yeah yeah yeah yeah how old was I then
no I no like 12.
wait no I I had a okay for some reason I
couldn't play it but I felt really left
out because everyone everyone was
playing yeah yeah I was like well I just
play it on my PC you've oh [__] you no
no that's okay
so then you know because I was I I felt
so left out that I wanted to play and it
seemed fun because you know because you
were doing the spoofing thing so yeah I
did this thing
you know I was farming and I got I was
like damn this shit's [__] boring
because I'm like walking around yeah no
[__] I was like when do I I was like
also at the time I was living in Wales
right right which is yeah which the
thing that I realized really quickly
about Pokemon go is that if you don't
live in a place that has stuff yeah
Pokemon go doesn't have a lot to offer
yeah yeah there was pretty much like two
things within like like 10 miles of
where I lived yeah I was like this is
[__] and so then I went I spoofed on the
map I clicked London I walked two feet
and I'd gone over ten poker stops and I
was like this is [__]
privilege once again so anyway I got
banned pretty quickly yeah okay I was
teleporting oh okay I was going like
India all right I'm going to Japan get
the Japan exclusive Pokemon all right
I'm going back playing Pokemon go in
Japan was like [__] happy I bet it
was because I didn't come out until
Monday I don't know why Australia got it
first yeah Australia got it first yeah
Australia we got it lost yeah and I'm
like what how does that make sense we
made it yeah well it's it's like the
Mario movie come not not coming out of
Japan yet right that's right no it's not
it's not on Japan yeah it's coming out
tomorrow yeah yeah
so for some reason when Japan like has
an IP that's Global now we get it last
in Japan for some reason detective
Pikachu came out first in Japan okay
yeah and I'm like okay yeah it'll just
make up your [__] head
at that point yeah I kind of missed the
Pokemon go crazy and I was like so salty
about it because I was living in
Thailand at the time yeah right and I
saw these YouTube videos about people
like going to parks and having these big
Pokemon go media
because I was like I had like this big
phase where I was like oh God I wish
that was me came out in Thailand and I
remember I was like yes I'm gonna go out
yeah walk to all these poker stops I
remember like going to my first pokestop
um it was about like 35 degree weather
in like with like 100 humidity and the
next stop was like a 20 minute walk
I start walking for about 10 minutes and
I'm like they're saying it man I can't
[__] do this will you look on one of
the first people to like I guess make
videos on Pokemon go because I I was
flicking through your channel everyone
was making videos yeah yeah but I was
looking through your channel and I saw
that you had a video from I think six
years ago which was like Pokemon go
let's play part one yeah it has like 20
million views or something yeah yeah so
that was because I was following the
kind of project the week's leading up
being like okay no this is gonna go
crazy surely Pokemon out there on the
phone
um and then it came out like on midnight
and I literally was like downloaded my
phone rang one of my mates up like out
in the suburbs I was like you gotta come
over right now get the camera we're
going outside of the middle of night
catch a [__] Charmander get here so
we were like running around catching
caterpies at 2AM and that's that video
yeah yeah you literally like first two
hours filmed yeah and then you I
presumably went home and edited it and
got it up bang oh and then I remember
going to bed waking up I think my
average views per video Back Then were
like 100 200k like over a week
especially back then and then like that
video I remember I went to bed after
grinding probably like five six a.m hit
post woke up and it was like on a mill
Mill and a half and I was like oh yes
hey yo we talking I'm on to something
here yeah so part two was the next I
woke up
round two let's go
let's go yeah no but it was like the
biggest flash in the pan like yeah after
a month it was dead right because you
couldn't you get you get your Pokemon
and that's it
I know they brought out the raids yeah
but it still didn't feel that but that
was also like I think it was like a year
after yeah yeah yeah I I hung on for a
bit because I was a bit hopy and
thinking it would come back uh it didn't
but I I remembered I did a couple things
so we went to Chicago for the raids and
they had like the first big Pokemon go
event and then like the servers didn't
work because it was too many people that
was fun yeah
um and then we did the Yokohama Pikachu
event oh yeah uh which I was talking
about last night and then they launched
Gen 2 and I was in Japan for that as
well but yeah and then it was done in a
year kind of yeah right and then
fortnite came out
no actually the first phone that I
filmed was a sponsored video oh really
because I I remember when fortnite came
out uh because I was I was playing FPS
games around that time and it was kind
of like it was not super big right away
like I think everyone remembers fortnite
just blowing up instantly but it was
pretty slow yeah very slow like Pokemon
go was definitely Bang Yeah Yeah but
like fortnite was like gradually over
time because it was still pubg I think
right and then yeah just a couple
updates came out the ninja started
getting these viewers going and then it
definitely hit the hit the yeah because
I was gonna ask I was like from from
someone who like I played like one
fortnite game and I was like yeah I
think it's not really for me personally
but like I've it's always been kind of
an anomaly to see because like you
always hear about like games blowing up
but I feel like the the blow up of
fortnite and like the magnitude they
grew to eventually was almost like
unprecedented like it was like at the
time there was not really a game that
had blown up that much like overnight
why why do you think it was like why why
was it Fortnight that you think was like
the game that just exploded and became
what it is today yeah you know what you
try to dissect it I actually don't know
because like yeah Minecraft was would
you say Minecraft would Minecraft
Minecraft was like a very gradual rise
yeah yeah yeah and then it just kind of
dominated Minecraft also had its like
ups and downs as well it was like yeah
for a little bit and then it kind of
came back yeah everyone thought
Minecraft was dead then I had a
Resurgence and it was dead again then
it's like always there's always yeah
it's never gonna die it's like Lego you
know what I mean it's it's like yeah it
will fall off like a month or two and
then it will come back because you know
the kids will always play you know it's
too many good mods yeah and I'm thinking
about going back and I thought I'd never
go back
but yeah I don't know it's hard I don't
know how fortnite like and even like
being a creative the time it was just
kind of like
it was pubg but the graphics looked for
me it was looking on the thumbnail like
the colors looked good vibrant yeah you
know when you compare it to like you
said pubg and H1 uh Z1 like they're all
really kind of ugly games yeah very
great it's like an ugly I mean it's just
ugly it's like cod that somehow looks
worse than Cod yeah one of these games
so yeah I think it's definitely that as
well it's very more it's easy to like
show a kid fortnite be like oh yeah the
saturation yeah like when you get a gun
it's a it's a gold gun it's like oh okay
this is all like kind of like hitting
the serotonin points in your head yeah
yeah that's true it's it's fun like even
if you're not good at it when you when
you find a purple gun like oh it must be
good and then it's like it sucks or
something yeah well you know you know I
feel like as someone who's like never
actually played a single game of
fortnite yes I am that person I like
fortnite for a while so yeah really yeah
what seasons oh [__] oh you're like
it was right for the season before
Thanos joined oh okay that was a good
one yeah okay I remember that because I
remember I quit and Thanos came out and
I was like just when I thought I was out
yeah just when I thought I was out they
dragged me right back in yeah and I
remember when that happened that was
insane that was wild yeah at this time
they hadn't done any collabs no it was
the I think yeah the first one and like
I started with a playable Thanos which
is mad but like I don't think anybody in
gaming had even done anything close to
that no no no no no and even even now
fortnite is getting all of the anime IP
like collaborations that the attackers
would you see that yeah Attack on Titan
Naruto Japan right now like yeah every
bus stop there's just like a [__]
huge ad for like oh the casa and Aaron
are in fortnite now they're just like
what is this timeline we're meeting a
lot about fortnite but I think there is
generally so much interesting stuff to
talk about before it's a case and how it
affects it online for sure yeah yeah
because like yeah like I said like a lot
of these IP like Naruto like my hero
Academia Dragon Ball it's some of like
the eyepiece that the Japanese are so
[__] protective over and have never
collabed with like like an outside kind
of like entity yeah like in in the
history of the industry so the fact that
what broke that curse was fortnite you
know as much as we meme it up is [__]
impressive no absolutely yeah yeah I I
wonder if they'll ever get Nintendo or
Pokemon my answer is no I don't think
they know like I think that's the one
that they yeah you're right they are
very protective I think there's another
level of that yeah these boys right here
the Mario boys they I don't think
they're gonna I just I just can't
imagine Luigi like emoting over a kill
you know
like Nintendo would never let Mario have
a gun man are you [__] kidding me
I think I think a lot of these companies
were protective but you know there's
definitely a sign that you know because
when you go to Japan you can see that
like you know Levi's on cleaning
products or um
you know they in Japan they're not
nearly as protective as they are
compared to like overseas so yeah they
clearly were open to licensing out the
the IP and the characters for stuff that
doesn't really make sense for the
characters I mean would leave out with
cleaning it does but yeah I have a Rumba
that uh the voice is just Levi nowhere
yeah so when you turn it on it's just
Levi being like it's time to clean
they obviously have a history of being
willing to give out the IP and I think
it was just a case of no one was writing
the big enough checks I think yeah yeah
it must have come along and offered some
crazy yeah system for it because I think
that's what it would take for them to be
like all right yeah I guess yeah sure
did you see that latest one-piece
McDonald's collab in Japan
yeah chicken they've remade the one
piece opening with like gold Roger uh
like having like a chicken burger
and reciting the uh reciting the opening
monologue we're like if you want to find
the chicken burger you can find it in
McDonald's
now yeah so it's it's obvious that they
are willing to work with IPS
um and yeah it's impressive that
fortnite has had this massive
International growth that has like
literally like reshaped the industry did
you know it was gonna like blow up or
was it kind of just like a feeling yeah
there's a feeling it was definitely a
feeling it was like kind of just like
and at the time like in this part of my
career I just gotten off the Pokemon go
hype train so I was very much just like
looking for the new kind of game to set
up on because I'm not I don't know about
variety a variety for YouTube in the
gaming Niche is is hard because like
you'll get viewers that come to watch
you for a certain game yeah you play
something else you have your viewership
and back then I thought the algorithm
was very based on like your average
viewership I don't know if it actually
was but that was just in my head
um so I'd just like to be on one game
and that way I could kind of do
different things with the one game and I
think it being this kind of malleable
game where you can use to to tell a
story or interact with the community
like it was it was perfect for me at the
time and it still is it's just
I I think a lot of what killed the hype
for like content creation on YouTube for
fortnite was just like Tick Tock to be
honest right right like it just like
sped everything up in it
you know you'd sit there back then I
used to upload like 30 minute videos in
fortnite and it'll be great you could
not get away with that today